automne 2020 les habitants du haut
karabagh déplore les dégâts d'une guerre
qui a fait 6000 morts
six mois après la fin des combats et une
défaite militaire de l'arménie face à
l'azerbaïdjan
un premier pas pour la paix entre les
deux nations a été effectué le président
azerbaïdjanais ilham aliev s'est dit
prêt pour des pourparlers avec erevan
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises que nous
étions prêts à commencer à travailler
sur un accord de paix avec l'arménie
afin de mettre fin à la guerre afin de
minimiser ou d'éliminer tout risque
d'affrontement militaire potentielle
nous avons besoin d'un accord de paix
nous avons besoin d'une délimitation de
la frontière avec l'arménie
tout cela nécessite des efforts
conjoints je ne pouvons pas le faire
unilatéralement bakou prône l'apaisement
au haut karabagh régions séparatistes
arménienne en territoire azerbaïdjanais
au coeur d'un conflit entre les deux
nations
l'arménie de son côté annonce la
préparation d'un accord avec
l'azerbaïdjan soutenu par la russie
les décisions sur lesquelles un accord
de principe a été conclue avec nos
partenaires internationaux sont à 100%
conforme aux intérêts de l'arménie
nous signerons ce document dans le cas
où l'azerbaïdjan respectera ce qui a été
convenu
malgré un cessez le feu signé sous
l'égide de moscou et le déploiement de
2000 soldats de maintien de la paix
russes les tensions persistaient dans la
région la semaine dernière
l'arménie accuse l armée azerbaïdjanaise
d'avoir violé la frontière dans le but
de contrôler des territoires que se
partagent les deux pays
des accusations rejetées par bakou la
voie diplomatique semble dorénavant
privilégiée pour rétablir les relations
entre les deux pays moscou
acteur majeur dans la résolution du
conflit au karabagh a proposé de prendre
part à une commission conjointe en tant
que médiateur